ur
président
la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage lundi le vice-président de
séance a partager avec vous l'émotion
qui nous a étraint après le drame euh
vécu à haras je voudrais simplement au
moment de ces questions au Gouvernement
rappeler à la fois la mémoire de cet
enseignant la souffrance aussi qui
étreint l'ensemble de notre communauté
nationale mais aussi la ville d'Arras
tout particulièrement et aussi les
élèves et qui ont vécu cela nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir je souhaite que
ça soit dans la dignité pour ce qui s
passé que nous puissions partager ce
moment madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site chacun sera attentif
au cours de nos échanges à une des
valeurs essentielles du Sénat le respect
qu'il s'agit du respect des uns et des
autres et bien sûr aussi le respect du
temps de parole et je vais donner la
parole à madame la Présidente Cécile
cuerman pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre en préalable j'apporte mes
condoléances à la famille de Dominique
Bernard victime d'un attentat terroriste
vendredi dernier samedi 7 octobre nous
avons tous été meurtris par l'attaque
terroriste islamiste du Hamas à
l'encontre de la population israélienne
des jeunes terminant un festival des
populations des kibou
ont été sauvagement abatttu violentés
pris en otage nous avons basculé dans
une inhumanité que nous pensions révolu
nous pensons à tous les otages dont nous
demandons la
libération depuis l'escalade à la
violence s'accélère les Palestiniens
sont victimes de représailles des
centaines de civils tués hier un hôpital
a été bombardé faisant des centaines de
morts en plus avec gravité
je veux dire ici que nous refusons de
trier les morts civiles le déplacement
exigé par le gouvernement de Benjamin
netaniaahou d'un million d'habitants de
la bande de Gaza est intolérable et
impossible il annonce un drame
humanitaire sans
précédent face à l'engrenage militaire
je reprends ici les mots d'Er Brunstein
président du Forum international de la
paix ancien collaborateur d'itzac Rabine
il n'y a pas de solution militaire au
conflit la seule solution sera
diplomatique je suis et je serai
toujours avec mon groupe une ardente
combattante de la paix dans la
continuité du combat de Jean
jorè la France doit faire entendre sa
voix dans le concert des nations elle
doit affirmer haut et fort le respect
des accords internationaux qui assoit la
création de deux états la fin de
l'occupation et de la
colonisation madame la Première ministre
faisant NRE les propos d'Antonio goutarz
secrétaire général de l'ONU nous
exigeons un cesser le feu immédiat la
France va-t-elle porter à l'ONU une
résolution en ce sens et faire reprendre
à tous le chemin de la paix si
indispensable à
l'humanité pour vous
répondre la parole à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente Cécile
cuckerman le 7 octobre vous l'avez
rappelé une attaque terroriste sans
précédent a touché Israël nous l'avons
condamné fermement à plusieurs reprises
encore avec vous la semaine dernière au
cours de cette attaque 24 de nos
compatriotes ont perdu la vie se sont
encore disparu et plusieurs sont
probablement retenus en otage à
Gaza face à l'horreur nous l'avons dit
Israël a le droit à la sécurité Israël a
le droit de se défendre dans le respect
du droit international
humanitaire comme l'a affirmé le
président de la République rien ne
justifie jamais que des cibiles soit
pris pour cible aussi à mon tour
permettez-moi de dire mon effroi face à
la frappe qui a touché l'hôpital àarli
de Gaza causant de nombreuses victimes
palestiniennes je veux avoir une pensée
pour les familles et les proches des
victimes cela ne fait aucun doute chaque
vie
compte les hôpitaux et le personnel
médical sont protégés par le droit
international humanitaire il doit
s'appliquer en toutes
circonstances dès hier le président de
la République a condamné très faire
cette attaque toute la lumière devra
être faite sur ce drame les auteurs
devront être identifiés et rendre des
comptes madame la Présidente cuckerman
dans ce contexte dramatique la position
de la France est très claire d'abord
nous sommes au côté de nos compatriotes
je tiens à saluer le travail de nos
diplomates mobilisés jours et nuits
d'ici ce soir nous aurons permis à 3500
de nos concitoyens de rejoindre la
France
la France demande la libération de tous
les état de tous les otages sans délai
sans conditions la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colona a rencontré
les familles dimanche à telavive et
comme l'a dit le président de la
République hier nous travaillons
activement à leur
libération plusieurs dizaines de nos
concitoyens sont par ailleurs bloqués à
Gaza dans une situation extrêmement
précaire nous les suivons
individuellement et faisons notre
maximum pour leur permettre de quitter
Gaza
ensuite je l'affirme à nouveau les
populations palestiniennes ne sont pas
responsables de la
situation nous avons annoncé un soutien
supplémentaire de la France de 10
millions d'euros pour l'aide humanitaire
à Gaza nous appelons à un accès
humanitaire immédiat à Gaza afin que
l'aide des Nations Unies puisse être
acheminée et parvienne aux populations
palestiniennes c'est une urgence des
milliers de vies en
dépende enfin sur le plan diplomatique
nous multiplions les contact avec les
pays de la région pour éviter l'escalade
et un embrasement
régional notre position est constante
une issue politique avec deux états
vivants en paix et en sécurité c'est le
seul horizon pour la paix aux Nations
unies la France soutiendra cet
après-midi le projet de résolution
présenté par le Brésil qui condamne sans
ambigué l'attaque terroriste tout en
rappelant la nécessité de permettre
l'accès de l'aide humanitaire et la
protection de la population civile de
Gaza madame la Présidente kckerman la
France cherchera toujours le chemin de
la paix elle sera toujours un artisan de
la sécurité et de la stabilité au Proche
Orient elle sera toujours du côté du
droit international c'est le sens de
notre mobilisation et elle continuera et
je vous confirme madame la Présidente
que le Parlement aura l'occasion de
débattre de la situation au Proche
Orient dès la semaine prochaine je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Marie vanlerenberg pour le groupe
de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
3 années ont passé la douleur de
l'assassinat de Samuel Patier est encore
présente rouverte à
vif par celui de Dominique Bernard à
haras Maville où l'émotion est à son
comble une fois de plus l'école est une
cible pour ceux qui en veulent à nos
valeurs qui en veulent à notre
République mais le terroriste a trouvé
sur son chemin des héros avec un
sangfroid admirable enseignant agent
policiers au péril de leur propre vie en
ont sauvé de nombreuses et les mots sont
trop faibles pour les remercier leur
rendre hommage et si le temps est au
deuil et au recueillement il n'occulte
pas tout à fait les questions après
trois décennies d'attentat et une
trentaine de lois l'arsenal juridique et
policier existe est-il suffisant
l'attentat d'arace montre
malheureusement qu'il y a des failles
alors pour autant
une aème loi de circonstances n'a guerre
d'intérêt j'en appelle donc à la sagesse
du Sénat pour trouver dans la future loi
immigration les réponses justes et
fermes mais il faut miser aussi et
surtout sur une véritable politique
éducative et parentale impératif pour
réarmer moralement la jeunesse l'école
doit demeurer un sanctuaire à l'abri de
la violence de certains foyers et des
idéologies mortifères un lieu où on
apprend et o on s'émancipe alors
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous avez rencontré des
enseignants à race bouleversés par le
drame ils attendent vos réponse à leurs
questions et je vous en pose deux
qu'allez-vous faire pour assurer la
protection des établissements scolaires
les grilles et les circulaires ne
suffiront pas et qu'allez-vous faire
aussi pour que le travail éducatif et
civique mené par Samuel Patier Dominique
Bernard et que même tous les enseignants
de notre pays ne soi pas 20
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur Gabriel Atal
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur van
lerenberg nous étions ensemble vendredi
àas nous y avons rencontré une
communauté
éducative profondément
traumatisée et nous avons rencontré une
communauté éducative
debout qui a fait le choix de rouvrir
l'établissement scolaire dès le
lendemain de l'attentat le samedi pour
accueillir les enseignants les élèves et
les familles je veux à mon tour comme
vous l'avez fait rendre hommage à leur
exemplaire mobilisation dans des
circonstances absolument terribles et
absolument dramatiques vous l'avez dit
Dominique Bernard est tombé en héros et
ses collègues qui sont intervenus sont
des héros mais des héros qui n'auraient
pas dû l'être dans de telles
circonstances la mission d'un enseignant
sa vocation c'est de sauver des vies par
la pédagogie pas de sauver des vies en
s'interposant entre un terroriste armé
et des élèves et donc notre
responsabilité absolue c'est d'apporter
à nos enseignants à tous les personnels
et aux élèves les conditions de la
sécurité pour que l'école puisse remplir
sa mission dans les conditions de
sérénité qui sont impérativement
nécessaires vous avez aborder deux
questions la question de la sécurité des
bâtiments j'ai rencontré ce midi
l'ensemble des présidentes et présidents
d'association d'élus donc comme
publierons une déclaration commune dans
les prochaines heures je peux vous en
livrer néanmoins la substance nous
sommes unis dans cet objectif de
protection de nos agents et des élèves
des efforts et des progrès ont été
conduits ces dernières années notamment
depuis 2015 où le gouvernement d'allor
avait engagé un plan massif de
sécurisation et des plans de mise à
l'abri qui je le dis ont probablement
permis d'éviter un carnage
supplémentaire à aras où la réaction du
personnel enseignant et éducatif a été
absolument exemplaire il faut
probablement aller plus loin et nous
sommes déterminés à y aller ensemble et
à travailler de concert et puis la
sécurité intellectuelle de nos
enseignants pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à assumer leur mission et
parfois à nouveau le faire puisque oui
l'école doit rester un sanctuaire je
suis conscient que dans certains
endroits elle doit le redevenir et ça
c'est une mission profondément
structurante sur laquelle nous aurons à
avancer tous ensemble pardon j'ai
débordé monsieur le Président d'autres
questions permett d'aller plus loin sur
ce sujet là monsieur le sénateur merci
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
deco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire monsieur le ministre vendredi
dernier 3 ans après l'assassinat de
Samuel pati domin Bernard est mort
poignardé devant son lycée il était lui
aussi professeur nos pensées vont à ses
proches ses élèves ses collègues c'est
la rich humaine qui fait toute la force
de l'éducation nationale mais elle
s'amenuise à travers nos enseignants
c'est le savoir et nos valeurs qui sont
attaquées l'école est en première ligne
mais l'école ne peut pas être la seule
réponse à cette violence qui trouve son
lit dans les fondrement de l'État social
au milieu de cela l'école doit rester un
lieu de transmission de savoir
d'émancipation un lieu où on apprend la
tolérance et le vivre ensemble un lieu
où la communauté éducative se sent
entendue malgré la sidération la colère
et la tristesse il va de soi que l'école
ne doit pas devenir une
forteresse lundi une minute de silence é
observée dans tous les établissements
scolaires hasard du calendrier la
commission d'enquête consacrée au
traitement des menaces et agressions
contre les enseignants reprenait ses
travaux à cette occasion la faiblesse de
la formation et la de la préparation à
la vie de classe des enseignants a été
pointée du doigt il y a 3 ans presque
jour pour jour j'avais interpellé votre
prédécesseur sur cette question rien n'a
changé on nous parle aujourd'hui d'un
retour aux écoles normales mais est-ce
vraiment le
cap hier devant la commission d'enquête
la sœur de Samuel paatti nous a appris
le défaut d'accompagnement
institutionnel auquel s'étaité son frère
alors qu'il cherchait un soutien et
protection avant son
assassinat mais aussi que les dernières
circulaires n'ont apporté aucune
amélioration dans la prise en compte de
la parole des enseignants cette surdité
institutionnelle est accablante au-delà
des discours de circonstance nous
attendons des actes et non des mots
monsieur le ministre quels seront les
vôtres pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'éducation nationale et
la jeunesse monsieur Atal merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice de Marco
merci d'avoir rappelé la mission
fondamentale de l'école qui est la
raison même pour laquelle terroristes
islamistes s'en prennent à notre école
les islamistes ils veulent éloigner le
plus grand nombre du savoir pour imposer
leur obscurantisme notre école accueille
tout le monde les islamistes ils veulent
soumettre les femmes notre écueil notre
école accueille toutes les petites
filles de France avec tous les petits
garçons de France les islamistes veulent
imposer le règne de la religion notre
école impose celui de la République et
de la laïcité c'est extrêmement
important de réaffirmer ces enjeux là
vous m'interrogez plus spécifiquement
sur la question du respect de la laïcité
à l'école et du soutien dû aux
enseignants en la matière je vous
rejoins totalement sur le fait que ce
soutien doit être absolu et qu'il passe
par des actes sur les questions du
respect de la laïcité à l'école j'ai eu
l'occasion à l'occasion de la dernière
rentrée scolaire de prendre une décision
qui me semble importante avec le respect
de la loi de 2004 sur les tenues
religieuses à l'école il me semble que
c'est un acte clair il me semble m
Catrice je le dis que certaines voies
politiquement ont manqué au soutien qui
me semblait nécessaire sur cette mesure
absolument nécessaire pour faire
respecter nos règles à
l'école je pense que nous responsables
politiques nous avons aussi une
responsabilité d'être uni derrière ses
valeurs et notamment la défense de la
laïcité dans notre école et derrière les
actes qui sont mis en place pour la
faire respter mais on est évidemment pas
au bout du sujet vous l'avez dit il y a
un enjeu de formation formation initiale
que nous sommes en train de refondre
profondément en lien avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
des enseignants j'aurai l'occasion de
faire des annonces dans les prochains
mois sur le sujet formationue et je le
réaffirme ici nous avons mis en place
une formation sur les questions de laïit
avec pour objectif que tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale on
parle d'un million près d' 1300000
agents et été formé d'ici à 2027 chaque
année il y a des centaines de milliers
de personnels qui sont formés c'est un
enjeu absolument structurant absolument
majeur pour les valeurs de notre école
et de notre République et j'espère
pouvoir compter sur l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale pour nous
accompagner la parole est au président
Jean-François rappin pour le groupe les
républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les mots ne réparent pas les cœurs les
mots n'assèchent pas les pleurs mais
parfois les mots réconfortent voilà les
quelques mots que j'utilise monsieur le
ministre quand il m'est demandé
d'entamer un éloge funèbre mais comment
voulez-vous que je puisse utiliser des
mots aujourd'hui pour porter
l'impensable en perpétuelle répétition
et reproduit à haras la semaine dernière
tant de colère nous envahit tous même si
l'on doit rester digne comme toujours en
de telles circonstances cette dignité
que l'on nous demande depuis toujours et
à chaque fois cette retenue
politiquement correcte dont nous sommes
coupables après le père Amel après Nice
après Charlie après le Bataclan et le
Stade de France après Samuel pati et
aujourd'hui après Dominique Bernard oui
c'est la colère qui nous submerge et
donc face à cette colère quels sont vos
mots et surtout vos actes pour tenter de
l'apaiser pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremè monsieur Gérald armanin merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rppin je partage les vôtres de
mots et votre
colère monsieur le sénateur dans la
région qui est la nôtre
sattaquer un
professeur avec la réaction extrêmement
digne et courageuse du corps enseignant
qu' évoqué le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec le courage des policiers
qui sont intervenus en moin de 4 minutes
pour interpeller le terroriste islamiste
il y a évidemment les mesures que nous
devons prendre sans faiblir
objectivement pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas il y a un texte
immigration qui arrive dans 3 semaines
au sein de votre hémicycle la commission
des Lois du Sénat l'a adopté avec
beaucoup de modifications je F mien les
modifications du
Sénat j'ai une boussole monsieur le
sénateur la fermeté la fermeté dans les
mesures que nous adopterons la fermeté
dans l'intégration la fermeté contre
tous les délinquants étrangers qui ne
peuvent pas rester sur notre sol quand
nous les
accueillons j'ai une autre boussole qui
guide chacun des femmes et des hommes
politiques c'est l'efficacité et je veux
dire au président du Sénat je veux dire
à l'ensemble des sénateurs que je vais
vers ce texte compliqué avec des idées
simples monsieur le sénateur s'il y a
des propositions supplémentaires d'où
qu'il viennent qui
permettront à n'importe quel moment et
conformément à ce que le gouvernement
essaie de faire depuis le début de
l'élection du président de la R r
c'est-à-dire avoir la
fermeté contre tous ceux qui veulent
toucher les valeurs françaises attenter
aux liberté publique
fondamentalement blesser la nation je
donnerai un avis favorable et je vous
invite monsieur le sénateur dans esprit
de concorde nationale dans un esprit qui
ressemble aux mots et aux actions d'y
travailler
ensemble
monsieur merci pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre et vous l'avez dit
la situation ne peut que perdurer si
rien n'est fait mais pourquoi en
arrivons-nous là parce que pendant des
années les ennemis de la France ont fait
l'objet de trop de tolérance alors face
à ceux qui nuisent à la France ou qui
vont nuire à la France nous ne pouvons
plus montrer de faiblesses et les
faiblesses elles apparaissent au grand
jour avec des expulsions ou des
obligations de quitter le territoire
prononcé légalisé par la justice mais
dénoncé et contrarié par une opinion
minoritaire de structure activiste mais
trop écouté et malheureusement
entendu monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre il ne faut pas se limiter à la
surveillance il faut agir contre les
ennemis de la République à ceux qui
n'aiment pas la France qu'ils partent
nous ne les retenons pas et surtout nous
ne devons pas les attirer ni en France
ni en Europe car moi la France je
l'aime la parole est à notre collègue
NAD JAV pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues dimanche à haras
lundi dans toute la France nous nous
sommes rassemblés pour rendre hommage à
Dominique Bernard enseignant assassiné 3
ans après que le fut Samuel pati tous
les deux victimes de la barbarie
celle-ci porte un nom le terrorisme
islamiste nous témoignons notre soutien
à sa famille ses collègues et à
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
nous saluons le courage de celles et de
ceux qui se sont interposés et des
forces de l'ordre intervenu rapidement
nous pensons aussi aujourd'hui à nos
amis belges et suédois eux aussi en
deuillés Dominique Bernard est mort
parce qu'il était enseignant un porteur
de flambeau et parce que le djihadisme
se projette contre l'école Dominique
Bernard est mort de s'être interposé
entre l'école qui est au cœur de notre
République et de sa promesse
d'émancipation et le fanatisme dont
l'objectif est exactement l'inverse
après haras comme après Conflant
saint-honorine il ne faut absolument pas
tomber dans les pièges tendus par les
défenseurs de cette idéologie mortifère
celle qui voudrait que nous fassions des
amalgames ou celui qui voudrait que nous
nous divisions il nous faut au contraire
nous rassembler derrière nos valeurs
communes et les réaffirmer parmi elles
la laïcité je pense à Caroline Fourest
qui avec d'autres défend ce qu'elle
nomme justement le génie de la laïcité
et qui dénonce depuis longtemps certains
renoncements à travers le pas de vague
ou par cynisme électoral elle rappelait
il y a quelques jours il faut arrêter de
penser que l'école laïque est
islamophobe il est tempant en effet que
certains Saisse de faire de l'école une
cible la laïcité c'est ce principe qui
permet de croire ou de ne pas croire
nous devons défendre ce gâre de
neutralité rappeler qu'il n'est pas la
source de nos problèmes mais la
condition de notre vie collective
monsieur monsieur le ministre il est
impératif que la parole puisse se
libérer lorsque des propos se font
menaçants comment mieux protéger nos
enseignants tout en réaffirmant ce cadre
qui nous est
cher pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur Atal merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice nadèj Ava
oui vous avez raison il faut que la
parole soit libre et pour que la parole
soit libre pour que les enseignants les
personnes de direction l'ensemble des
équipes éducatives puisse signaler un
certain nombre d'atteintes à nos valeurs
et au principes de laïcité notamment il
faut qu'ils aient l'absolue conviction
que quand ils le font ils sont soutenus
et qu'ils sont suivis et ça passe je le
dis par une attitude qui doit être d'une
très grande fermeté et d'une très grande
clarté hier se sont tenus avant-ier
pardon se sont tenus partout en France
des hommages à la mémoire de Samuel pti
et de Dominique Bernard j'avais été
extrêmement clair à la veille de ces
hommages en indiquant que toute
contestation que toute provocation que
toute perturbation donnerait lieu à des
sanctions exemplaires et à la saisine de
la justice nous en sommes à près de 360
signalements de contestations de
perturbation qui s'apparentent parfois à
des menaces de mort ou à l'apologie du
terrorisme ce sont autant de
signalements que je fais au procureur de
la République autant de procédures
disciplinaires qui sont engagées et je
le dis pour les cas les plus graves
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux j'ai
demandé au chefs d'établissement
l'exclusion sans délai de ces élèves
sans attendre la réunion des conseils de
discipline je pense que si nous ne
sommes pas ferme et clair nous
n'arriverons pas à faire appliquer nos
règles à l'école j'entends certains ou
je lis ici ou là certains qui parlent de
criminalisation d'élèves mais le crime
ça serait de laisser faire ça ça serait
de ne pas réagir et donc je le dis ici
je le réaffirme oui il y aura et je
continuerai à avoir une très grande
fermeté sur le sujet en rappelant deux
règles élémentaires le souvenir de
professeurs qui sont tombés pour l'école
on ne le piétine pas on l'honore et
l'autorité de l'école et de la
République on ne la conteste pas on s'y
soumet la parole est à notre collègue
Louis Vogel pour le groupe des
indépendants République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Samuel Patti Dominique
Bernard comment en sommes-nous arrivés
là l'école républicaine est en principe
le lieu où chacun peut tirer le meilleur
de
lui-même l'école républicaine c'est
aussi le creuset de notre démocratie le
meilleur moyen d'intégrer et de souder
notre communauté nationale
or nous avons laissé le pacte
républicain être entamé grignoté par
petitbout en
réalité nous sommes aujourd'hui engagés
dans un combat de valeurs les valeurs
républicaines contre l'intégrisme les
lumières contre
l'obscurantisme la démocratie contre le
fanatisme ce n'est pas un hasard si les
professeurs d'histoire sont les
premières cibles dans ce combat
les enseignants tous les enseignants
sont en première
ligne leur témoignage se multiplie ils
dénoncent ces agressions verbales ou
physiques les intimidations qu'ils
subissent au quotidien qui sont
aujourd'hui amplifié encore par les
réseaux sociaux et leur
immédiateté au même titre que les élus
les professeurs sont les meilleurs
garants de l'ordre
républicain les enseignants doivent
pouvoir transmettre nos valeurs communes
en toute liberté pour leur permettre
d'exercer leur métier nous devons
assurer bien sûr leur protection mais
cela ne suffira
pas nous devons plus valoriser leur rôle
peut-être organiser les enseignements
notamment civiques de façon les laisser
moins seul dans l'accomplissement de
leur mission peut-être intervenir dès
leur formation pour mieux les préparer
et continuer d'être ce qu'ils ont
toujours été les hussards de la
République Monsieur le Ministre l'heure
est grave que compte vous faire pour
mieux protéger et mieux aider nos
enseignants dans l'exercice de leur
mission essentiel à l'existence même de
notre
démocratie monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur Atal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Louis vugel un enseignant sur
deux déclare s'être déjà autocensuré
dans ses enseignements par crainte des
réactions ou de
représaill lié à ses enseignements c'est
dire combien le phénomène est
structurant il concerne vous l'avez dit
les professeurs d'histoire géographie il
peut aussi concerner des professeurs de
lettres des professeurs de philosophie
des professeurs de sciences de la vie et
de la terre dans un certain nombre de
d'enseignement ce phénomène nous devons
le regarder en face et nous devons être
absolument
implaca si nous voulons lutter contre
l'autocensure la première des choses à
faire c'est d'être en toute
circonstances au côté de nos enseignants
en les soutenant lorsqu'ils font face à
ces situations qu'il les signal et en
étant exemplair en matière de sanction
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est de rappeler toujours en
toute circonstan ce qui n'est pas
toujours fait que la relation entre un
enseignant et ses élèves ça n'est pas
une relation d'égal à égal il y a celui
qui sait et qui a l'autorité de son
savoir et il y a ceux qui apprennent ça
paraît comme cela l'évidence mais
malheureusement ça n'est pas l'évidence
ou ça n'est plus l'évidence partout dans
notre pays il est nécessaire de toujours
le rappeler la troisième chose et vous
l'avez dit c'est de travailler avec les
enseignants probablement pour quand
c'est à leur demande quand ça vient les
soutenir dans leur enseignement adapter
parfois le format de certains cours si
ça leur permet prodiguer ces leçons en
toute sérénité il y a la possibilité ça
a été évoqué par des enseignants que
j'ai rencontré sur le terrain
effectivement sur certains sujets vous
avez évoqué la laïcité d'avoir le
renfort de personnes exérieur interne au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale nos
formateurs laïité nos équipes laïit
valeur de la République dans l'é
lectorat qui viendrai soutenir les
enseignants à l'occasion de ces cours à
la demande évidemment des enseignants
concernés pour décharger une partie du
poids de la responsabilité de cet
enseignement face à certains élèves ça
fait partie des pistes que je regarde et
que je travaille avec les organisations
syndicales représentatives des
enseignant mais je sais que je pourrais
compter sur la représentation nationale
pour avancer sur ce chantier qui est
fondamental pour notre école et don donc
pour notre
République
merci la parole est à notre collègue éic
gold pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre alors que
l'école devrait être comme disait Jan
l'asile inviolable où les querelles des
hommes ne pénètrent pas un enseignant a
une nouvelle fois été assassiné au sein
même de son établissement aujourd'hui se
m les sentiments de colère de révolte et
de sidération le groupe RDSE aussi aux
hommages rendus depuis vendredi à nobque
Bernard tombé parce que professeur tombé
parce que comme l'aurait dit jores il
tenait entre ses mains l'intelligence et
l'âme des enfants lieu d'instruction et
d'inclusion d'apprentissage de la
liberté de la liberté de conscience
l'école est devenue une cible la son d'
race a attaqué à dessin le symbole d'une
république laïque où le lieu se forme
l'IT l'esprit critique qui questionne
les croyances et permet l'émancipation
il a grandi en France a été éduqué dans
l'école de la République la même où il a
été où il a décidé de frapper au-delà de
l'obscurantisme du fanatisme ce drame
doit nous interroger sur notre modèle
républicain et sa
pérenité lors d'une récente question au
gouvernement j'avais souhaité vous
interroger sur les réponses apportées à
la banalisation de la violence au
quotidien elle prend ici une forme
particulièrement horrifiante mais comme
en juin dernier je veux vous parler de
culture
citoyenne de solutions de moyen et de
long terme pour soutenir les équipes
éducatives porter les valeurs
républicaines et valoriser le sens de
l'engagement dès le plus jeune
âge je sais votre gouvernement attentif
à ces sujets notamment à travers le
déploiement du service national
universel vous nous trouverez à vos
côtés dans ce combat le groupe RDSE
portera ainsi dans quelques semaines une
proposition de loi initiée par notre
collègue Henri Cabanel visant à
renforcer la culture
citoyenne des propositions pour
permettre à chacun de s'inscrire dans un
projet commun de trouver son rôle et sa
place dans une société apaisée aussi
Monsieur le Ministre quels sont vos
projets pour renforcer les outils
d'éveil à la citoyenneté et favoriser le
vivre
ensemble monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur éic
gold rappel ici quelle est la mission
fondamentale de l'école le rôle de
l'école c'est de former des républicains
et des citoyens éclairés et
j'ajouteraiis et nous en avons la
conviction en partage que c'est de
former une communauté de républicains et
de citoyens éclairés et pour cela vous
avez raison la question de
l'enseignement moral et civique ex
éducation civique est absolument
fondamentale nous avons engagé des
travaux sur le sujet mon prédécesseur
avait saisi le Conseil supérieur des
programmes pour nous éclairer sur une
refonte de l'enseignement moral et
civique les constats ils sont connus
d'abord il n'a pas lieu partout puisque
il est souvent et peut les comprendre
une forme de variable d'ajustement pour
terminer les programmes pour certains
enseignants ce qui veut dire qu'on doit
aussi repenser l'ampleur de certains
programmes ensuite dans ses objectifs et
dans son contenu il doit être revu
beaucoup de choses s'y sont ajouté on en
perd parfois un peu les objectifs et
enfin on doit probablement en renforcer
la présence le volume horaire pour un
certain nombre d'élèves et pour un
certain nombre de classes nous allons
avancer sur ce sujet-là avec priscevno
la secrétaire d'État évidemment chargée
des questions d'engagement et de
citoyenneté et je le sais avec la
représentation nationale j'étaé
auditionné devant la commission des
affaires culturelles et de de
l'éducation avec le président Lafond et
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que je
souhaitais avancer notamment avec le
Sénat qui travaille beaucoup sur ces
questions dans les prochains mois et
puis il y a le déploiement du service
national universel vous avez un projet
auquel je tiens beaucoup je l'avais
lancé en 2018 en tant que secrétaire
d'État priscateven aujourd'hui le
poursuit je veux profondément en faire
un moment clé dans la formation des
citoyens en France ce qui impliquera
peut-être de le faire évoluer mais en
tout cas je crois profondément que nous
devons aller vers la généralisation du
service national universel pour que
l'école puisse assumer pleinement cette
mission et nous en partageons tous je
crois l'objectif de former une
communauté de républicains et de
citoyens éclairés et unis je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
Daras pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
vendredi alors que les manifestants
quittaient tranquillement la place des
Héros au terme de leur défilé dans le
cadre du débat démocratique qui fait
l'identité et la grandeur de notre pays
les R d'arace retentissait des sirènes
hurlantes des forces de police et de
secours à quelques dizaines de mètres
Dominique Bernard tombait sous les coups
de couteau d'un individu animé par une
idéologie terroriste islamiste haras le
pas decalais et la France entière étaiit
cruellement frappé par la barbarie au
cœur de la mission la plus noble de la
République l'éducation de ses enfants
l'horreur absolu s'abatit sur nous nous
replongeant dans les funèbres souvenirs
des attentats de janvier et novembre
2015 faisant écho à l'assassinat de
Samuel pati et nous rappelant qu'il est
encore possible en 2023 de mourir par le
seul fait de transmettre le savoir la
République est en deuil je veux ici
rendre hommage au courage et saluer la
mémoire de Dominique Bernard assurer sa
famille de notre soutien former des vœux
de rétablissement au blessés exprimer
notre entière solidarité avec les élèves
et les membres de la communauté
éducative permettez-moi également de
saluer la réactivité et le courage de
nos forces de sécurité et de nos
services de secours en ce temps de deuil
prenons la mesure de ce qui nous
rassemble autour de ce que nous avons de
plus cher les valeurs de notre
République la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité et la laïcité et rappelons
avec détermination que la République et
la nation doivent faire bloc face au
fanatisme monsieur le ministre vous avez
établi un lien entre les événements qui
se sont déroulés en Israël et cet
attentat faisiez-vous allusion au climat
de haine et à l'effet de contagion
engendré par ces événements où avez-vous
connaissance d'une entreprise organisée
et coordonnée au-delà des cellules
terroristes familiales ou isolé sur ou
hors le territoire national qui viserait
particulièrement notre pays alors que
nous sommes passés en alerte urgence
attentat pouvez-nous nous éclairer sur
la bonne manière de résoudre la
redoutable équation qui permet de
concilier la fermeté contre le
terrorisme et le respect de l'État de
droit inventé par nos lumières et
marqueurs des démocraties adulte tel que
la
nôtre pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'intérieur des Outremers monsieur
Gérald armenin merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur depuis
que je suis ministre de l'Intérieur je
ne de cesse de rappeler aux Français que
la menace terroriste et singulièrement
la menace terroriste islamiste est
extrêmement
importante 43 attentats islamistes
déjoués par les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur 1 tous les mois et demi 1500
personnes interpellées qui ont un lien
direct avec de l'apologie du terrorisme
des préparations d'attentat depuis 5 ans
6500 personnes par an que nous mettons
sous technique de
renseignement expulsion des 922 fichiers
s irrégul du territoire national il y en
avait
1142 voilà 5 ans 48 89 aujourd'hui
encore sur le territoire national don
plus de la moitié sont en prison et
l'autre moitié sont soit en centre de
rétention administratif soit signé à
résidence soit en effet en contentieux
juridique et j'espère que la loi
immigration ne permettra d'aller plus
vite plus fort et plus ferme et en effet
monsieur le sénateur s'il n'y a pas de
menace organisée exogène à notre
connaissance la menace organisée exogène
du fait de la situation au Sahel du fait
de la situation au Proche Orient du fait
la situation en Afghanistan au Levant
nous fait penser qu'en Europe il se peut
que ces cellules se reconstitues mais la
menace principale vous le savez c'est
une menace endogène une ubérisation
pardon de ce mot du terrorisme qui
attend la publication des caricatures
des soi-disants blasphèmes des
soi-disants difficultés qui toucheraient
le monde particulier pour lequel ils
seraient attachés dans leur
fantasmogorie des complots sur Internet
qui peut-être permet de passer à l'acte
parce qu'un diodisme d'atmosphère existe
du fait malheureusement d'un écosystème
islamiste que nous devons combattre et
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement par la
loi séparatisme par les lois terrorisme
par le courage de service de
renseignement combat donc oui monsieur
le sénateur s'il n'y a pas de menace
caractérisé et organisé du fait même des
événements dramatiques et des des
attaques terroristes islamiste contre
Israël il est évident que le climat
n'est pas positif et que la menace est
très forte et je veux particulièrement
avoir une pensée bien sûr aussi pour nos
compatriotes de confession juives qui
ont peur et pour lequel la République
les protège chaque jour et chaque
lu la parole est à notre collègue
Annique Pétrus pour le groupe les
républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse alors qu' double hommage au
professeur Dominique Bernard et Samuel
paatti lâchement assassiné par des
thoristes islamiques leur a été rendu
une rage sourde et une crainte certaine
envahissent le monde enseignant comment
peut-on mourir d'enseigner en France en
2023 j'ai passé plus de 35 ans de ma vie
en tant qu'enseignante et j'étais
heureuse de me rendre à mon
établissement chaque matin aujourd'hui
cela ne serait certainement plus le cas
l'école est maintenant de vu la cible du
terrorisme nous en avons la confirmation
avec ce tragique événement à la colère
et la tristesse que nous éprouvons
s'ajoute aussi les froid à l'idée que
n'importe quel enseignant peut-être
aujourd'hui une cible dans une société
de plus en plus violente il se retrouve
souvent bien seul face à des assaillants
qui peuvent profiter d'un interclasse
pour rentrer tranquillement dans un
établissement scolaire et tuer ils sont
tous tous aussi démunis face à leur
hiérarchie nos enseignants veulent un
siècle de parole pas une minute de
silence le bras le long du corps la
montre en main ils veulent vivre pour
enseigner éduquer instruire et élever
c'est leur mission leur destin monsieur
le ministre nos enseignants attendent un
soutien clair et sans faille de l'État
alors quel moyen entendez-vous mettre au
service de nos établissements de notre
école afin qu'elle puisse assurer sa
mission essentielle celle de transmettre
nos valeurs mais aussi comment
comptez-vous réarmer nos enseignants en
leur et leur assurer une formation à
l'image de ce que furent les écoles
normales à la fin du 19e siècle je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la
jeunesse merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice russe oui vous avez
raison notre école a été la cible des
terroristes islamistes parce qu'elle
promeut des valeurs qui sont
profondément contraires à ce que les
terroristes islamistes défendent eux et
l'Ance c'est que notre école ne cède
jamais un Yota sur ces valeurs qu'elle
défend et oui vous avez raison depuis
vendredi dernier ça avait éé déjà le cas
après l'assassinat de Samuel pati 860000
enseignants se rendent dans leur
établissement en se disant ça aurait pu
être moi et notre responsabilité c'est
de leur apporter la sécurité
j'aiindiquais tout à l'heure que j'ai
rencontré l'ensemble des associations
d'élus ce midi nous sommes unis dans
notre détermination à leur apporter
cette sécurité et il faut toujours le
dire et le rappeler madame la sénatrice
beaucoup d'investissements et beaucoup
d'efforts ont été réalisés ces dernières
années vraiment en matière de formation
au sein des établissements pour mettre
en sécurité lorsqu'il y a une alerte
intrusion en en matière d'équipement
pour lutter contre les intrusions
extérieures et limiter au maximum le
risque d'intrusion extérieure dans les
établissements mais évidemment il faut
continuer toujours à aller plus loin et
c'est ce sur quoi nous nous sommes
accordés ce midi avec les associations
d'élus et je le dis puisque vous posiez
la question des moyens l'état évidemment
ne s'est jamais dérobé de ses
responsabilités en la matière au
contraire depuis 2017 et c'est sur le
budget de mon collègue géralde Darmanin
du ministère de l'Intérieur ce sont 100
millions d'euros qui ont été consacrés à
la sécurisation d'établissements publics
locaux dans le cadre du FIPD qui a
permis notamment de soutenir des
collectivités locales pour la
sécurisation d'éces par exemple et
évidemment que nous allons continuer
accompagner les collectivités locales
dans ces investissements pour la
sécurisation vous aurez l'occasion
d'avoir les débats budgétaire
prochainement je suis certain que ça
fera partie des sujets sur lesquels vous
allez travailler dans votre rôle de
parlementaire pour que l'État puisse
avec les collectivités locales en toutes
circonstances continuer à agir pour
assurer ce que nous devons à notre
communauté enseignante et à nos
personnels la sécurité de leur
établissement pour la sérénité de leurs
enseignements je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
après toutes ces questions d'une gravité
tout à fait compréhensible et toutes ces
question nécessaire lié au drame que
notre République a vécu la semaine
dernière je suis obligé de changer de
sujet ce n'est pas chose aisée mais je
le fais en questionnant monsieur le
ministre du Travail dans le cadre de la
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
pour savoir si monsieur le ministre vous
nous confirmerez aujourd'hui que vous
avez réellement l'intention de
ponctionner un à 3 milliards d'euros
dans les caisses de l'agir Carco et quel
sont vos
arguments pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur
du merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Lubin
madame la sénatrice vous m'interrogez
sur AG Carco peut-être est-ce l'occasion
pour moi avant que vous puissiez me
répliquer vous l'avez prévu je crois de
revenir sur un certain nombre d'éléments
laag Carco est géré par les partenaires
sociaux et c'est une caisse
complémentaire qui est bien gérée bien
gérée notamment parce qu'il y a 4 ans
les mêmes partenaires sociaux
organisation syndical organisation
patronale on voté la mise en place d'une
décotte d'un malus sur les pensions de
retraite à titre provisoire mais un
malus sur les pensions de retraite de ce
partant avant 65 ans la Carco dégage des
excédents c'est une bonne chose et nous
considérons que la réforme des retraites
telle qu'elle a été présenté au
Parlement et publié au mois d'avril
dernier va permettre à horizon 2026 de
générer des excédents supplémentaires
sur les excédents de la girc 2026 le
gouvernement considère qu'un milliard d'
n'existeraiit pas sans la réforme des
retraites et les services de la gircarco
les services de la gircarco considèrent
que sur les excédents de la girc 2026 1
milliard n'existerait pas sans la
réforme des retraites vous pouvez
constater madame les sénatrices qu'entre
1 milliard et 1 milliard 2 l'écart n'est
pas si
grand nous avons demandé avec madame la
Première ministre que dans le cadre des
négociations menées par les partenaires
sociaux cette ce rendement
supplémentaire puisse être consacré à
participer au retour à l'équilibre
général les partenaires sociaux ont fait
un autre choix et ont décidé de dépenses
qui n'était pas prévu une revalorisation
au-delà de ce qui se fait habituellement
et la suppression de la décotte pour les
retraités actuels comme pour les futurs
retraités c'est 1 milliard d'euros de
dépenses sociale en plus en 2026 c'est
un milliard d'euros de dépenses
publiques puisque les dépenses de la
gircco sont comptabilisées dans les
dépenses pu publ tel qu'observé par
l'Union européenne nous avons dans les
prochaines années donc dans les 3 ans
qui viennent à la fois trouver des
marges pour revenir sur ce milliard
d'euros et nous continuons les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
pour voir comment ces excédents
supplémentaires pourraient participer à
un retour à l'équilibre général du
système de
retraite madame lu monsieur le ministre
je suis heureuse de vous entendre dire
que les excédents de l'agir Carco sont
liés à des sacrifices qui ont été
consentis par les salariés du secteur
privé de ce pays qui a à partir de la
génération 1957 ont accepté une baisse
de 10 % du montant de leur retraite
complémentaire pour enflouer les caisses
de l'agir Carco c'est à la suite de
cette génération de 1957 la génération
qui arrive et qui devait prendre sa
retraite se voit obligé de travailler de
3 à 2 ans de plus et c'est grâce à cela
nous dites-vous que les les les réserves
de la GIR Carco vont encore s'améliorer
et que donc il faudrait qu'ell soit
utilisée
pour combler un éventuel déficit des
retraites autrement dit les salariés
dans ce pays sont ceux qui font tous les
sacrifices ce sont ceux qui acceptent de
payer de de percevoir moins de
retraite ce sont ceux qui acceptent de
travailler plus longtemps ce sont ceux à
qui on ne peut absolument pas proposer
au moins un grand débat dans ce pays sur
les salaires les salariés sont
décidément la force vive de ce pays et
pourtant une force vive de ce pays que
ce gouvernement n'a pas l'air de
beaucoup aimer j'en veux pour preuve les
propos du ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement qui a osé
fustiger ces irresponsables de
partenaires sociaux le mot n'a pas été
prononcé mais il était bien entendu
sous-entendu qui allait dépenser leur
argent plutôt que de le donner au
gouvernement pour combler le déficit
qu'il n'est pas capable de combler par
ailleurs faut concl
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Fabien
Jeunet pour le GR PL
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre votre
gouvernement a publié hier les montants
définitifs que percevront les
collectivités au titre du filet de
sécurité énergétique ce soutien de
l'État était attendu et je veux relayer
ici les profondes inquiétudes des maires
confrontés à l'explosion de leurs
dépenses gétique à l'inflation à
l'augmentation des charges de personnel
mais aussi à la remontée des taux
d'emprunt ce soutien était d'autant plus
attendu qu'il devait appuyer la
formidable mobilisation des élus locaux
pour faire face à cette dégradation des
conditions budgétaires pour trouver des
solutions pour faire des économies pour
investir pour plus de sobriété le Sénat
vous avait alerté madame la Première
ministre sur ses réels besoins des
collectivités dès l'été 2022 et avec
Mathieu Darnaud et un certain nombre de
collègues nous vous avions mis mis en
garde contre l'usine à gaz des critères
inventés par Bery finalement ce filet
s'est transformé en véritable NAS une
Naas pour les 22000 communes à qui le
gouvernement avait initialement promis
un soutien une Naas insidieuse qui au
final ne soutient que 2942 collectivités
soient 10 fois moins qu'annoncé une
naass qui n'aurait pas déplu au marquis
de sad puisque les critère de Bery
contraignent maintenant près de 3500
collectivités à rembourser la compte
perçue alors qu'elles ont pourtant vu
leurs dépenses exploser dans mon
département de la sonellloire près de
deux communes sur trois ayant perçu un
acconte vont devoir le rembourser dans
ces conditions madame la Première
ministre réalisez-vous qu'après le
piteux échec de vos contrats de
confiance ce dispositif est devenu le
filet de la défiance entre l'État et les
collectivités
locales pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Jeunet à l'été 2022 vous n'avez pas été
parmi les derniers à plaider ici au
Sénat pour que dans le cadre de la loi
de finances rectificative un article 14
soit ajouté à cette loi de finance
rectificative pour prévoir un filet de
sécurité doté de 430 millions d'euros en
à une époque où spontanément la totalité
du gouvernement n'était pas
immédiatement convaincu de la nécessité
de mettre en place un filet de sécurité
qui avait matière à soutenir les
communes qui impacté à la fois par la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et par
l'augmentation du prix d'indice nous
avons conjointement dans le cadre de
cette construction arrêté trois
principes et un montant montant revu à
la hausse par le Sénat arrêté à 430
millions d'euros et trois critères faire
en sorte d'avoir une épargne brute qui
soit inférieure qui ne soit pas
inférieur à 22 % avoir un potentiel
fiscal qui soit pas égal à plus de deux
fois la moyenne de la strate et enfin
avoir une épargne brute qui baisse de
manière effective de 25 % sur l'année
considérée par définition et ça je sais
que vous le savez que personne ne le
conteste tant que nous n'avions pas les
comptes administrative de l'année 2022
on ne pouvait pas arrêter la liste
définitive puisque dans ces critères le
constat devait se faire à partir du mois
de juin la consolidation des chiffre par
la LG FIP a conduit à ce qu'il y a
quelques jours on arrête cette liste il
y a deux manières de lire les choses la
façon dont vous le dit c'est des
communes ont touché des accomtes et il
apparaît à la fin de ce processus sur la
base de ces critères que nous avons
partagés qu'elle n'y avait pas
droit quelques chiffres 4000 à compte la
plupart assez faible 3000 bénéficiaires
mais pour un montant
consolidé qui est de 405 millions
d'euros donc très proche de la somme
globale que nous avions considéré et des
sommes qui sont parfois très
significatives 9 millions pour l 7
millions pour Rennes et si je vais sur
d'autres collectivités des sommes
importantes pour bourge je vous donne
l'application des critères du principe
dans votre département de la soné Loire
Monchanin 374 € Mons min
275000 le gouvernement a appliqué les
critères votés par le Parlement et a
ventiler les crédits Monsieur
Je finalement monsieur le ministre V à
la sécurité ce que le match de dimanche
soir était à la coupe du monde de rugby
un immense espoir devenu une terrible
déception comme l'équipe de France les
collectivités ont joué le jeu avec
pugnacité avec rigueur et engagement
mais à la fin c'est toujours Bercy qui
gagne le match en ne dépensant que 405
millions d'euros sur les 430 budgetés
c'est très injuste c'est très frustrant
et c'est surtout monsieur le ministre
très révélateur du peu de confiance que
les collectivités peuvent porter à votre
action gouvernementale
la parole est à notre collègue Amel
gacer pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du Logement il y a
quelques jours le Congrès HLM réunissait
les acteurs du logement social à Nant le
constat est accablant le chiffre ne
cesse de grimper aujourd'hui 2,5
millions de ménag sont en attente d'un
logement social alors que seul 85000
logements seront mis en chantier cette
année annoncé à cette occasion les
mesures du gouvernement pour le logement
vont dans le bon sens soutien à la
transition écologique bonification des
prêts à la production et prorogation du
prêt à à taux zéro pardon pour
l'accession sociale mais je ne vous
apprends rien en vous disant que ces
mesures ne permettront pas d'enrayer la
crise profonde que nous traversons
monsieur le ministre l'histoire nous
enseigne que l'État est massivement
intervenu à chaque crise du logement
après guerre dans les années 50 dans les
années 70-80 pour le logement social
pourtant aujourd'hui votre gouvernement
ne semble pas avoir pris la mesure de la
situation en témoigne le projet loi de
finance 2024 qui va nous être soumis
répondre à la pénurie de logement
sociaux dynamiser le parc privé loger
nos étudiants massifier la rénovation
thermique iser l'accession à la
propriété loger les plus fragiles jamais
les enjeux n'ont été aussi nombreux ce
que je vous demande aujourd'hui ce que
vous demandent les acteurs du logement
c'est un discours de vérité c'est un
discours de clarté monsieur le ministre
face à toutes ces urgences quelle est
votre stratégie quelles sont vos
priorités vous le savez la politique du
logement est une politique de temps long
les professionnels du secteur manquent
cruellement de visibilité allez-vous
répondre les attentes et surtout avec
quels moyen je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
délégué en charge du logement Monsieur
Patrice
vergri vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre
monsieur monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice le gouvernement est
parfaitement conscient de la crise du
logement et a engagé un certain nombre
de mesures fortes pour y répondre et
déjà dans le cadre du projet de loi
finance 2024 et je vais y revenir de
manière
détaillée déjà sur l'accession à la
propriété parce que le but du jeu des
mesures que nous souhaitons mettre en
œuvre c'est qu'elles ont pour
spécificité de toucher l'ensemble des
fondamentaux de la politique du logement
c'est pas une recette magique
particulière c'est tous les fondamentaux
sur l'accession à la propriété
renforcement du prêt à taux zéro il a
été recentré sur les zones qui on avait
le plus besoin aujourd'hui mais
rebooster avec des plafonds des baremes
qui qui augmente et au total un
élargissement des publics au total c'est
70 % de nos concitoyens dans les zones
concernées par le PTZ c'està-dire les
zones qui en ont besoin qui vont être
concerné par le nouveau préato zé au
lieu de 50 % par avant les plafonds du
bail réel solidaire ont été remonté nous
avons donné là les moyens d'avoir au
total plus de pré àau zéro que l'an
passé alors même alors même que nous
avons des taux à 3,8 % aujourd'hui soit
un prêt à tau zéro beaucoup plus
incitatif on pourrait continuer sur le
logement locatif social vous l'avez
évoqué 1,2 milliards apportés aux
rénovations énergétiqu plus de 14
milliards de prébonifiés de la Caisse
des dépôts à la fois sur la rénovation à
la fois sur la production et le
mouvement HLM à la différence a signé
cet accord parce qu'il a bien compris
effectivement qu'il y avait des
possibilité d'accélérer les choses et
d'ailleurs sur l' bien sûr que si je le
dis puisque le mouvement Hlm a
effectivement signé cet accord parce
qu'il a compris lui effectivement qu'il
permettait de relancer la production et
la rénovation énergétique
j'en viens aux autres mesures qui sont
dans le projet de loi de finance vous
aurez des choses sur le foncier vous
aurez des choses sur le locatif
intermédiaire mais je voudrais vous
rajouter encore une mesure que sous
l'impulsion de la du président de la
République et de madame la Première
ministre j'ai pu annoncer ce matin la
création d'une nouvelle démarche
territoire engagé pour le logement qui
permettront sur une quinzaine
d'agglomérations les plus tendues en
France de développer et d'accélérer la
production de logement et dans les jours
qui viennent j'aurai l'occasion d'écrire
au préfet pour justement identifier ces
sites les plus en
demande madame
gaker quelques
secondes et bien de ce que je comprends
tout va très bien dans le meilleur des
mondes je pense que nous ne voyons pas
les choses de la même façon je ne doute
pas des efforts que vous faites mais à
aujourd'hui nous n'y voyons toujours pas
clair visibilité s'il vous plaît merci
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Cyril pelva pour le groupe les
République merci Monsieur Merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues depuis près de 6 ans les
habitants d'un immeuble situé àmas dans
mon département sont confrontés à une
situation ubuesque une des
copropriétaires et des complices ont
constitué un faux syndicque sur simple
déclaration auprès de l'ANA et s'en sont
servis pour petit à petit prendre
possession de l'immeuble dans un premier
temps ils se sont appropriés les partis
communes et ont facturé de fausses
prestations copropriétaire le véritable
syndque a cherché à porter plainte pour
ces faits en 2022 le dépôt de plainte au
commissariat lui était refusé au motif
qu'il s'agissait de simple problème de
voisinage l'obligeant à porter plainte
directement auprès du procureur mais
aucune suite n'y a été donnée par la
suite leescroocerie est monté d'un cran
deux appartements vides ont été spoilés
par les escros et loué à l'insu des
propriétaires qui ont porté plainte fin
2022 pour occupation illicite en
septembre 2023 voyant sûrement qu'il
pouvait agir en toute impunité faute de
suite donné aux plaines ils ont cette
fois expulsé frauduleusement les
locataires de de les locataires de deux
propriétaires et en non signé en leur
nom des faux bails avec des occupants
illicites leur permettant ainsi
d'empocher les loyers si la police a
récemment procédé à des arrestations
elles ne sont intervenues qu'après la
médiatisation de cette affaire il est
inconcevable dans un état de droit que
de telles pratiques qu'on pouvait
qualifier de mafieusees ait pu perdurer
si longtemps et cette affaire soulève
plusieurs questions d'abord comment
est-il possible que l'ANA est accepté
l'immatriculation et le remplacement du
véritable syndicque par le faux la
procédure pour vérifier la véré des
documents fourni sont beaucoup trop
légères et totalement non sécurisé
d'autre part comment expliquez-vous le
refus de la plainte du syndicque et pour
quelle raison les arrestations
sont-elles intervenues seulement suite à
la médiatisation de l'affaire la
représentation nationale a pourtant voté
cette année une loi permettant
d'expulser plus rapidement les
squatterurs monsieur le ministre je sais
l'imence ce travail fournis
quotidiennement par les forces de
l'ordre mais des lacunes dans le
traitement des plaintes font que les
Français victimes de squat en sont
réduits à recourir au tribunal
médiatique pour faire avancer leur
dossier que comptez-vous donc faire pour
remédier à cette situation afin que les
plaintes pour squat soient traité
rapidement et efficacement je vous c'est
ver
gr monsieur le ministre délégué en
charge du logement vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le le
sénateur j'entends la situation
spécifique d'anemas elle méritera un
examen mais on pourra peut-être échanger
de manière plus approfondie sur Anma
spécifiquement mais je veux vous dire
que le gouvernement c'est largement
mobilisé pour lutter et prévenir toutes
les situations de squat et au côté des
parlementaires c'est mobilisé pour
simplifier et accélérer toutes les
mesures qui permettent de de régler ces
situations les moyens aujourd'hui
existent et et pas simplement au pénal
mais déjà au pénal depuis juillet 2023
d'ailleurs vous l'avez évoqué monsieur
le sénateur les peines maximales pour le
délit de violation de domicile ont été
triplés pour être porté à 3 ans dans
emprisonnement et 45000 € d'amende et
d'ailleurs à cette occasion un délit
d'occupation frauduleuse des locaux à
usage divers a élargi le spectre du
squat aux autres types de locaux en
dehors du domicile avec des peines
maximales porté à 2 ans d'emprisonnement
et 30000 € d'Amand donc on voit
effectivement que sur la dimension
pénale l'objectif est de laisser et de
ne pas laisser les choses impunies mais
vous avez raison il s'agit pas
simplement d'impunité il faut aussi
pouvoir libérer les lieux et depuis 2020
des procédures qui permettent au préfet
d'accélérer les expulsions ont été mis
en place
et permettent aujourd'hui au préfet
d'intervenir dans les 48 heures qui
suivent la mise en demeure en 2021 ce
sont 170 propriétaires qui ont ainsi pu
récupérer leurs locaux leur
domicile dans les quelques jours qui ont
suivi la mise en demeure donc vous le
voyez monsieur le sénateur vous pouvez
être convaincu que le gouvernement
s'attaque à défendre ce droit
constitutionnel qui est le droit à la
propriété merci à vous monsieur
PV la parole est maintenant notre
collègue David Ros pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
j'imagine que depuis plusieurs mois vous
avez pu mesurer à quel point les
finances locales sont exercé face à des
tensions budgétaires
importante alors que les conseils
municipaux s'apprêtent à voter avec
grande difficulté leur décisions
budgétaire modificative les mauvaises
nouvelles financières tombent de concert
avec les les feuilles autonnales ainsi
après les répercussions de
l'augmentation du point d'indice en
compensation l'impact de l'inflation sur
le coût du service public la baisse
contrastée constatée drastique des
droits de mutation de près de 30 % voilà
que l'on prend connaissance de la
publication de l'arrêté fixant le
montant définitif du filiet de sécurité
on y découvre que le nombre de
bénéficiaires est encore plus faible que
prévu pourtant le Comité des finances
locales vous avait alerté quant aux
difficultés opérationnel à venir
concernant un dispositif qualifié de
trop peu trop tard et trop compliqué
résultat alors qu'initialement vous
annonciez avec enthousiasme un soutien à
plus de 22000 collectivités ce nom
baissé à 11000 en novembre 2022 pour
finalement atteindre celui de 6531 et là
douche froide il serait demandé à près
de 3500 comm de rembourser les sommes
perçues votre dispositif serait ainsi
passé d'un objectif initial de 22000
communes à moins de 3000 monsieur le
ministre confirmez-vous ces chiffres
allez-vous réellement et sérieusement
exiger ces potentiels remboursements qui
mettrai en difficulté voir précarité
financières les collectivités concernées
enfin quel dispositif de soutien
financier envisagez-vous de mettre en
place en 2024 pour aider les
collectivités locales face à l'implation
et au coût de
l'énergie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur
Béchu monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Ross je suis heureux que vous
me laissiez quelques secondes
supplémentaires pour revenir sur la fin
y compris sur la métaphore choisie par
le sénateur
Jeunet le Parlement a décidé de critères
ces critères précisément contenu des
critiques qui se sont fait jour il y a à
peu près un an ont conduit à ce que le
filet de sécurité pour l'année 2023 soit
sur tous les bancs modifiés pour être
assoupli en passant des trois critères
qui aboutissent à la situation du décret
du 13 octobre à deux seulement le fait
d'avoir un potentiel financier inférieur
au double de la moyenne et une baisse de
l'épargne brute non plus de 25 mais de
15 %. la somme qui a été votée au PLF
n'était plus de 400 millions mais de 1
milliard et demi d'euros pour tenir
compte de cette réalité donc de deux
choses l'une est-ce que au titre de
l'année 2022 le filet de sécurité a été
aussi large que il ne l' en 2023 non ça
n'était ni les mêmes critères ni le même
montant est-ce que pour l'année 2023 la
manière dont nous accompagnons les
collectivités a été rehaussée oui
puisque vous avez vous-même décidé de
faire en sorte de resserrer les mailles
là où elles avaient été trop larges en
2022 il serait paradoxal de nous
reprocher de ne pas avoir respecté les
termes du vote du Parlement sur les
trois critères et sur le niveau du
montant sur la réalité des communes qui
ont perçu des accomtes et qui vont avoir
à rembourser ces accomtes de quoi
parlons-nous la réalité en nombre de
communes n'est pas celle que vous
décrivez je le redis 4000 communes en
tout ont touché des accomtes et dans les
accomtes qui ont été versés il y a une
soixantaine de millions d'euros qui ont
été versé à des communes qui ne
les justifient pas à l'issue des calculs
le rest rest a été voté à des communes
qui ont été consolidées pour celle-là
les consignes données à la DG FIP et de
lcer sur plusieurs années en fonction
des niveaux puisqu'on a des disparités
entre certaines pour lesquelles ces
avances sont importantes et d'autres
pour lesquelles elles sont extrêmement
faibles monsieur
Ros puisque puisque le ministre aime les
métaphores permettez-moi de vous dire
que ce filet est davantage un filet de
pêche qui visait à draguer les communes
et que les mailles étaient si larges
qu'une grande partie des collectivités
s'en sont trouvé exclus quand à celles
qui devront rembourser elles
considéreront ce filet davantage comme
un outil qui les aura fait plonger que
les aider à sortir la tête hors de
l'eau la parole est à notre collègue
Alain CADC pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'État à la mer monsieur le
ministre dans le cadre du Plan dit
Ukraine la pêche française a pu
bénéficier d'une aide d'État euro
compatible de 20 centimes par litre de
carburant ce plan se termine à la fin de
cette année et vous aviez décidé
d'arrêter le versement des aides au 15
octobre afin d'éviter les retards de
paiement ce qui a provoqué évidemment
une légitime levée de bouclier des
professionnels le gazol principal poste
de charge des pêcheurs n'ayant cessé
d'augmenter en 2023 alors Vous annoncez
à grandfor de communication lors de
votre visite au guilvineek une
prolongation de cette aide jusqu'au 4
décembre ce qui vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues ne change rien
puisqu'elle s'inscrit dans les dates
limites fixées par la Commission
européenne par ailleurs vous annoncez
pour 2024 un accord avec le groupe Total
pour la mise en place d'une ristourne de
13 centimes à la charge du pétrolier
dans le cadre de l'introduction de
biocarburant dans le
gazol pouvez-vous nous confirmer cet
accord son
neurocompatibilité si on veut pas tomber
dans les affres du fpap 2004 2006 où les
pêcheurs avaient dû rembourser les aides
perçues et sa durée sachant que la mise
en œuvre d'une telle mesure prendra
beaucoup de temps et que peu de pororts
peuvent aujourd'hui fournir du
biocarburant par ailleurs monsieur le
ministre dans une période où on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire et après le
plan de sortie de flotte brexit qui a
amputé notre capacité de production de
manière significative le moment est
enfin venu de faire entendre la voix de
la France à Bruxelles auprès de nos
partenaires européens la situation est
grave voulons-nous la mort de la pêche
française disparition qui nous obligera
à importer encore davantage de produits
de la mer de pays-tiers qui ne respecte
aucune de nos normes environnementales
et sanitaires monsieur le ministre notre
modèle de pêche français doit être
sauvé pour vous répondre la parole estô
secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer
Monsieur Hervé Berville monsieur le
ministre avez la parole merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Alain
CADC comme vous je partage le fait que
la pêche est une activité qui est
essentielle pour nos territoir essentiel
pour notre souveraineté et nous devons
accompagner nos pêcheurs tous les
pêcheurs parce qu'ils font un métier
difficile un métier qui est essentiel
pour les territoires littorau c'est
parce que nous croyons en l'avenir de la
pêche que depuis plus d'un an nous avons
soutenu de manière forte constante et
continue
nos pêcheurs la voix de la France est
entendue à l'Union européenne puisque
c'est grâce à la France et à la demande
de la du président de la République et
de la première ministre que nous avons
prolongé par quatre fois l'aide
carbulant cette aide n'a aucun
équivalent dans d'autres pays européens
et n'a pas de précédent c'est 75
millions d'euros qui ont été accordés
aux pêcheurs pour qu'ils puisse
continuer à sortir et puis c'est surtout
une prolongation bien évidemment dans la
durée mais une augmentation du plafond
quand je suis arrivé au responsabil le
plafond est à 30000 € pour les pêcheurs
il est désormais à 330000 € donc l'État
a été au côté des pêcheurs il continue
d'être au côté des pêcheurs et nous
allons continuer la mobilisation et
c'est la raison pour laquelle en août
j'ai demandé à ce qu'il puisse avoir une
prolongation de ces carburant pour
l'année 2024 et nous puissions augmenter
le plafond et donc ogilvinex ce n'était
pas un exercice de communication que
nous avons fait c'était des actions très
concrètes attendues par les pêcheurs
nous allons prolonger les carburant
jusqu 4 décembre et d'ici là nous
attendons une réponse positive et nous
portons le combat au niveau le plus haut
possible pour avoir une prolongation de
l'IDE de carburant mais au-delà de ça
monsieur le sénateur notre
responsabilité c'est aussi de préparer
l'avenir et c'est d'engager dès
aujourd'hui la transition énergétique du
secteur de la pêche toutes les grandes
crises de la pêche sont des pêches du
carburant et donc nous avons également
annoncé 450 millions d'euros pour
réduire la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles pour à la fois avoir une
souveraineté énergétique une souverainé
alimentaire donc vous voyez monsieur le
sénateur nous sommes au côté des
pêcheurs et nous allons continuer à les
soutenir la parole est à notre collègue
Annique JAC pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la transition
énergétique et concerne la mise en œuvre
de la loi portant accélération des
énergies renouvelable du 10 mars
2023 afin de porter la part d'énergie
renouvelable dans notre consommation
finale d'énergie à 33 % d'ici 2030 ce
texte permet aux communes de définir les
zones d'accélération où ell souhait
prioritairement voir des projets
d'énergie renouvelabl
s'implantter suite à une réunion
organisée récemment dans le département
du dou en présence des élus locaux des
services de l'état des principaux
acteurs du marché de l'énergie de
nombreuxes questions sont remontées sur
les difficultés d'application de cette
disposition elles ne sont pas propres à
mon territoire en témoignent les
expériences similaires vécues par
plusieurs de mes collègues comme vous le
savez les élus doivent rendre leur
proposition avant le 31 décembre
2023 sachant qu'à ce jour les décrets
d'application ne sont toujours pas parus
et que d'ici là ils doivent identifier
les zones
d'accélération sur leur territoire
modifier les documents urbanisme avec
les zones d'exclusion organiser la
concertation avec la population et nous
savons tous que ça ne se fait pas de la
même façon ni dans le même temps dans
des communes de petite taille ou dans
une grosse agglomération inscrire ces
zones sur le portail numérique dédié qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait
opérationnel aussi je souhaiterais
savoir comment le gouvernement entend
répondre aux inquiétudes des élus locaux
sur la mise en place de ces Z AER dans
le délai parti quand seront publiés les
décrets d'application tant attendus dans
nos territoires si ces décrets seront
bien conforme à l'esprit de la
loi voilà sans ces garanties les élus
peuvent difficilement entamer
sereinement leur démarche je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre de la transition
énergétique madame panier
runach merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les S madame la
sénatrice Jacques met je vous remercie
pour votre question qui témoigne de
votre engagement sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelabl dont nous avons
tant besoin pour sortir des énergies
fossiles après le large vote de la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables par cette assemblée dont
je salue à nouveau le le travail nous
avons décidé ensemble de mettre les élus
locaux au cœur du processus de
planification énergétique c'est un gage
de réussite de la planification écolog
logique porté par le Président de la
République et la première ministre
concrètement que dit la loi que les
maires ont désormais la possibilité de
définir des zones d'accélération sur
lesquelles ils souhaitent que soi
développé des énergies renouvelables et
des zones d'interdiction sur lesquelles
ils ne souhait pas que soi développé des
énergies renouvelables ces nouveaux
pouvoirs permettent de soutenir les élos
locaux qui s'engagent dans
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables il leur ouvre la
possibilité de bénéficier de nombreux
avantages qui sont ouvert par la loi en
particulier le partage de la valeur de
ces projets madame la sénatrice je veux
d'abord vous dire qu'il n'y a pas besoin
de décret aujourd'hui pour définir ces
zones d'accélération puisque toutouses
les actions qui sont prévues par la loi
mises en place d'un portail
cartographique nomination de membres de
l'équipe préfectorale pour être les
points d'entrée de chacun des élus en
responsabilité référent des énergies
renouvelables ont été prises c'est
mesures sont en œuvre aujourd'hui et
j'ai d'ailleurs écrit en juin à aux
35000 maires et président
d'intercommunalité pour leur donner tous
les éléments pour permettre leur
permettre de définir ces énergies
renouvelables et déjà un certain nombre
de communes aujourd'hui prennent des
délibérations pour définir ces zones
fort heureusement il naurait pas demandé
de modifier leur plu ou leur documents
d'urbanisme ce qu'on leur demande c'est
de préciser quelles sont les zones sur
lesquelles ils souhaitent qu'il y ait
des énergies renouvelables et le
remonter euh au niveau du département
puis de la région pour que les comités
régionaux de de l'énergie puissent
prendre position et je veux vous
rassurer la date du 31 décembre n'est
pas une date butoire mais nous ne
pouvons pas ralentir aujourd'hui les
communes qui ont déjà fait ce travail et
nous serons en soutien et nous le
faisons puisque j'organise tous les mois
des conférences et des visos avec plus
de centaines d'US sur ce sujet
plî mes chers collègues par lettre en
date de ce jour le gouvernement demande
l'inscription à l'ordre ordre du jour du
mardi 24 octobre après-midi d'une
déclaration suivie d'un débat en
application de l'article 50-1 de la
Constitution relative à la situation au
Proche Orient acte et donné de cette
demande ce débat pourrait avoir lieu mes
chers collègues à partir de
17h30 nous pourrions prévoir que les
orateurs des groupes à raison d'un
orateur par groupe interviennent selon
l'ordre décroissant de leur effectif
avec les temps de parole suivant 14000
pour le groupe les républicains 12
minutes pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain 10 minutes
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste 8
minutes pour les autres groupes 3
minutes pour un sénateur n'appartenant à
aucun
groupe le délai limite pour les
inscriptions dans le débat serait fixé
notez le bien au lundi 23 octobre à 15h
y y a-t-il des observations je n'en vois
point il en est décidé par ailleurs le
gouvernement demande également le
retrait de l'ordre du jour des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
qui était inscrite le mercredi 8
novembre ça me rappelle quelque chose en
conférence des présidents monsieur le
ministre acte et donné de cette
demande
j'informe que le le Sénat que
candidature pour siéger au sein de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur le projet de loi
pour le plein emploi ont été publié ces
candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n pas reçu d'opposition dans
le délai d'une heure prévu par notre
règlement merci les membres du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 25 octobre à 15h je
vais lever la séance la prochaine séance
aura lieu lundi 23 octobre à 16h pour
l'proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relative aux
services express régionaux métropolitain
la séance est
levée